>> WISCHERKEN: Hello everybody. Welcome to
a Filmmakers@Google night in Santa Monica.
I'm Julie Wischerken and I'm here to introduce
Chris Mason Johnson. Chris began his career
as a dancer and he once danced with Mikhail
Baryshnikov. He got a film degree from Amherst
College and worked as the Head of Development
at Open City Films and a script editor for
several studios. And he co-wrote, produced,
and directed his first feature, "The New Twenty,"
which will be screening tonight. And now Chris
will tell us a little bit about the movie
and please join me in welcoming Chris.
>> JOHNSON: Hello, everybody, eating Korean
barbecue at the Google office in Santa Monica.
All right, so this is an independent feature
film that, as Julie said, I directed and co-wrote,
and produced. It's genuinely independent.
I raised the money myself from private equity
and edited it on a laptop with final cut.
So if you have questions about all that angle
on it, we can talk after the--after the screening.
But for a brief intro, what I'd like to just
tell you is how the story began, actually
the film. It started in New York when my good
friend, Ishmael, came over and told me about
a bachelor party that he'd been to a few nights
before. It was a bachelor party for a mutual
friend. And it was one of those parties that
got pretty extreme. They had hired a couple
of strippers, they had a hotel room in a very
swank hotel, and I was not invited even though
we were all really good friends. And the reason
I wasn't invited is because I am not completely
heterosexual and they are. So there were sort
of these lines drawn. That is--we were a group
of friends, a group of buddies, right? We
went to college together, some straight, some
gay, we hung out together. There weren't the
usual divisions that you know from the stereotypical
films or TV shows that deal with those issues,
right? It wasn't like "Here's the segregated
gay show and here's all the buddies bonding."
It was a mix. But when it came to the bachelor
party, I wasn't invited. So clearly even though
we're dealing with the new male here for whom
these old divisions are not as strict, there
are still some divisions. Anyway, so the party
got very extreme and almost sort of, you know,
Carlos Castaneda-like in its mushroom enhanced
bacchanalia. And I was just fascinated by
this. You know, by the idea of this group
of guys hanging out together in this very
erotic way, something that simply could not
have happened even 20 years ago because there
was just too much tension around sensuality
between straight male friends. You just couldn't
do it. So I thought, "All right, this is some
kind of evolution here." At the same time,
there are still these lines drawn, again,
because I wasn't invited. So he told me the
story of this party. And I said, "That sounds
like a pretty good screenplay idea." And he
said, "Well, why don't we write it." And I
said, "Okay." And we were both just ready
for that in our life at the moment, so we
embarked on this project that became a year's
long project. So the bachelor party in the
movie is not anything like what happened in
real life. So fiction evolves. So you won't
see anything of what I just described exactly.
So again, what I was interested in was depicting
this like a group of buddies who were not
all straight. And when you see buddy movies,
they're all straight. Now in the Judd Apatow
movies, a lot of the jokes are around homosexual
panic. I think the whole premise is built
around that. You know, "I love you, man."
The whole thing is built around that. But
nevertheless, they're all straight. So, I
simply haven't seen it before. And the only
place I'd seen a mix is in the family dramas,
you know, "Six Feet Under", "Brothers and
Sisters", or if there's a mix of guys and
girls, and it's sort of a pseudo family-like
reality bites. There'll be the one gay subplot,
right? So I simply hadn't seen this mix. And
I was interested in it because it was something
that I think is happening in life. We're sort
of, you know, is this the post-gay generation,
right? Obviously not, but in some sense, yes.
So, we're seeing it play out now with marriage
equality, right? The younger you are, the
more likely you are to be pro-marriage equality.
So we're in this evolutionary moment where
these things are just not a big deal. People
would rather not talk about him. Yeah, he's
gay. So what? Get over it. It's not a big
deal, right? But at the same time, there are
still these divisions. So that's represented
in the movie in a couple of ways. Tension
between the guys who are buddies and who are
over it, but for whom there are still tensions
that often play out in humor. And then tensions
between an older generation who might be more
explicitly homophobic, and the younger generation
of guys. So, that was the original inspiration.
And the other thing I'd like to say before
we start the film is I didn't think that I
had written and directed a gay film. It was
just an ensemble drama about a group of people.
And I didn't want to ghettoize it as a gay
film because I felt the sort of moment of
great queer film had maybe passed. We'd had
a burst of it and then there had been some
films a bit--a little bit later. And I thought
we were in like a phase of these kinds of
pandering movies with like a shirtless hunk
and sort of soft core and I didn't even want
to see them and I didn't really want to be
associated with them. That was sort of my
prejudice. But someone sent a screener to
festival programmers at Outfest and they called
us and they invited us. That's a big gay and
lesbian festival in Los Angeles every summer.
And we debated it long and hard, you know,
"Should we ghettoize ourselves," et cetera.
And some people advise against it in very
strong terms. And they were very wrong. We
did it and it was the best thing we cold have
done, because, well, here I have. This is
what our poster was initially, which I think
was on your flyer. It's a group of faces of
the cast. And it says, "30 isn't what it used
to be." And then, you know, this is what we
became, which is a very different demographic
that's being targeted there. So, you know,
you're a tiny independent movie. We recently
had a theatrical in New York and LA, iTunes
July 1st. But you don't have a lot of marketing
money. And what the gay festival did for us
was it gave us an actual market we could target.
And as it turns out, that market was really
hungry for smarter content that wasn't pandering.
You know, that wasn't the latest Uncle Tom
version of gay film, right, that actually
reflected something from life. So that was
a wonderfully positive thing. The irony though
is that some of our most receptive audiences
have been women. We have a couple here tonight.
Because it is a relationship film and women
have just responded really strongly to it
and straight young men, so it's sort of a
double-edged sword. It gave us a market that
as a tiny independent film we could target.
And that helped up financially. In New York,
we were in the top 5 for Indie box office
per screen average of the quad opening weekend.
The other side of that double-edged sword
is--I do regret that I haven't been able to
reach a wider audience who really do respond
to this film, because in that other sense,
it's not a gay film. So if you like it, tell
your friends. iTunes, July 1st, on demand,
July 1st, nationwide in Canada. And without
further ado, enjoy the film. Thank you.